[موسيقى]
الذين راى اليوم ولو
المستوى
ملاحظه انني
لهذا الرهان ولكن من العديد من المواصفات
والحاجه الثانيه ان هذه الرهانات لا يمكن
النظر اليها كريهنات فرد فرديه
وتاتي في حاله كذلك ازمه مثل ما وصفناها
في الاسئله
ولكن
ويمكن التشابك هذه الرهانات تؤدي الى
معناها مبيعات تكون اكبر واسرع على
البشريه كامل
[موسيقى]
الهدف الهدف خلق الثروه والانتاج وتوزيع
الانتاج والمردوديه وما الى ذلك الحاجه
الاخرى الذي يجب اصلاح كذلك كل هذه ال ال
ال ال ال ال
الاموال التي للبعيده والغير مراقبه
وتكاليف المخفيه هناك العديد من التكاليف
المعرفيه التي لا نتحدث عليها في في
مواضيعنا مثلا ممكن ناخذ مثالين المثال
الاول هو المناخي والمثال المناخي لماذا
وصلنا لهذه الحاله لانه لمده سنوات وعقود
هناك البعض وفي بعض المناطق لو يسون هناك
تكلفه على المناخ ولم ناخذ بعين الاعتبار
هذه التكلفه في في همم في في كلفه الانتاج
وفي البيع ولماذا نتحملوها جميعا لانه
هناك لم نكن نقدم هذه
[موسيقى]